so the White House Press carry doesn't
despite the title exist to convey
information but to withhold it and in
this White House the press secretary
bans any reporter who has real questions
and that includes and it especially
includes a man called Simon atiba Simon
atiba is the most famous and we would
say finest reporter in all Africa and
that means that Korean Jean-Pierre does
not want to talk to him at all she
hasn't called on him in more than four
months now the White House says the
Korean Jean-Pierre will not meet with
Simon atiba until next year which of
course means never simonativa is with
Today News Africa he joins us tonight
Simon thank you so much for coming on so
on what grounds will she just not meet
with you
first of all thank you for having me
talk of course your show it's the most
World show and I'm always glad to be
here you know has the voice of Africa in
the U.S I love the US I always love
freedom I love democracy and even if you
paid me a hundred million dollars to
move to China I will not moved to China
I would like to be in the U.S because
the ideas of the US is the ideals you
know that those are the things that I
love and those are the things that most
African also love I feel like Karen Jean
Pierre she has no clue what's happening
in Africa she doesn't understand that
China is expanding and also spreading
this information and misinformation
against the U.S that they are competing
against the U.S competition is good but
then when competition comes with
destroying democracy and that becomes a
problem and she doesn't know that that's
why she discriminated against me she's
not called on me for the past four
months and so last week I tried to meet
with her she told me she will not meet
with me until 2024 Maybe
I
would she doesn't call on you because
she doesn't want to hear about Chinese
influence in Africa
yes I I feel like she doesn't take
serious questions she wants to have
questions that she she's received in
advance she doesn't want I ask tough
questions I ask tough question I I may
ask about you know many things that
happened in Africa including immigration
for instance how does it make sense that
Africans who are here for instance who
came legally apply for Asylum legally
have to wait for six years for their
cases to even be heard
and and their cases are now heard after
six months but they see people crossing
just walking across the border and then
they have all the benefit the next day
how is that fair to Africans
well that uh it seems like a completely
reasonable question and you have the
authority to ask it Simon and tea but we
are rooting for you in the White House
briefing room we hope they'll change
their minds and stop what they're doing
but in the meantime you always have a
place here on the show thank you good to
see you
thank you for having me
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight